thanks Moses all right yeah thanks to
the organizers for this Workshop it's
super fun
so this talk is gonna basically be an
overview of a line of work many of us
have been involved with and how we
estimate certain variable models and how
basically tensors have Arisen in certain
statistical machine learning problems
statistical estimation problems in a
very natural way and
you know two of the problems we're going
to highlight are this mixture of
gaussian's problem where you see a bunch
of points like this and you would like
to figure out the means of each cluster
classic statistical problem uh the kind
of discrete analog of this problem is
you know topic modeling problem or you
have collections of documents and you'd
like to estimate the topics in these
documents
you know most of the stock is going to
be reviewing things I've spoken about
before but I'll highlight some work on a
recent result looking at hmm so an
interesting
question
for just modeling discrete time series
suppose you have something like you know
a DNA sequence
so okay so you observe the sequence and
it's a natural deposit that there's some
pin structure in this and the way the
sequence is generated is based on some
memory so the state you know there's a
state here that's transitioning and that
encodes the the information and you see
these sequences and you'd like to build
a model of
this hidden structure and what's
interesting about this problem that's
pretty different from these is these we
think of as kind of high dimensional
observations okay this one's low but
typically when we're clustering a point
sort of in a high dimension of space
when we're dealing with words the number
of words in the English language is like
10 to the four whereas here are
observations are
rather low dimensional there's four
discrete objects
so I'll highlight some results here but
it's it's kind of a different problem uh
the challenges we face in this setting
so what's our goal here we see data we'd
like to estimate these this hidden
structure both efficiently from a
cystical point of view and a
computational point of view
right and what's used in practice well
these really are long-standing problems
and often what we use in practice are
iterative methods like k-means em Gib
sampling and we don't have a very good
understanding of their convergence
properties
like statistical efficiency in the
number of some the number of samples
that's right and you know that there's
sort of even information efficiency
we'll discuss which is like Notions of
window size like how long of sequences
do I need to to keep around for this hmm
problem
Okay so
uh
in terms of lower bounds well we know
this mixture of gaussian's problem in
the worst case can be hard because you
can have these examples that you know
basically you can make one gaussian
look like this is a very nice example by
Greg and Encore you can kind of make
wine gaussian look like a mixture of a
few of them that are reasonably well
separated basically just like by the
convolution theorem you're gonna have to
kind of fuss with the Tails a bit but
somehow you can you can make a mixture
of you can basically make sorry one
gaussian
look like a mixture of K gaussians and
these are reasonably well separated and
the point is if I give you an example
like this and ask you which one it is
you know this should be but just think
you know Augustine is a convolution of a
bunch of other gaussians you can fuss
around with it and get it to work out
and the point is this sort of problem
they're reasonably well separated would
be poly in K where K is the number of
gaussians but then remove samples you're
going to need to distinguish these two
is going to be exponential in k
okay and this is a hard case because
these parameters in parameter space are
super far apart
it's not like you know certainly as you
you know some gaussians get close
together it's going to be hard but this
is a very different problem these are
parameters are nowhere near each other
yet you can't distinguish them so we
know this case has to be hard but what's
interesting about
this hmm problem is a very different
hard case that we know of okay so this
is we can really think of a statistical
lower Bound for hmms there's this um
sort of this classic problem in csta
called it in learning theory called
Purity with noise so this is so let's
forget about noise suppose
we have you know a set of zeros and one
so we have a vector X1 to xn
this is binary
and you're going to see some Target why
and it's just going to be the Sun
let's just say a very small number
of variables but it's going to be some
mod two right so you know zero plus one
plus one will be zero and so on okay and
if there is no noise in this so
basically there's maybe five a small
number of them that are relevant you see
examples
there's just some arbitrary distribution
of our X's but if there's no noise in
this system you see a bunch of examples
and you'd like to learn these relevant
variables this is an easy problem
because it's gaussian elimination you're
just solving a linear system
right and the parity with noise problem
is
now you see you know zero one one and it
should be zero but someone's adding a
little noise to the problem
and it's clear that gaussian elimination
is a disaster now
right and and this is really a tricky
problem because we have no idea how to
solve this but it's an interesting one
because statistically there's no problem
like if we didn't have computational
resources
this is an easy problem
so it's really a good hard case it's not
like these MP hard problems it's the
kind of thing that crypto people build
Primitives of because how the heck you
know we just have no idea how to solve
it and what's interesting about this
hard case the main point I'm bringing it
up is you can embed these hard cases in
hmms the basically what you're seeing is
some zeros and ones for a while and then
after a while you see a parody at some
time step
that's corrupted with noise
and this sort of suggests that
computationally we should not expect to
learn General hmms and kind of for
different reasons in this lower Bound
for the gaussian mixture model because
it's sort of worse in in a lot of ways
because statistically this is an
instrument that we know is learnable
with a small number of samples but it's
really you know
there should be no way around uh this
this hmm so it's interesting to consider
what are the cases which makes problems
hard and you know to some extent the
highlight of this talk is under certain
assumptions uh that are pretty natural
we can get around these hard cases and a
number of interesting practical cases we
basically have a nice close form
Solutions of estimating these model
parameters through the use of certain
tensor decompositions and
and to some extent what's going on in
these problems you just need a little uh
genericness to your problem to break
these hard cases but it's sort of
different in each case and this talk I
really focused on
two of these simple problems which are
this topic model problem and a very
simple version of this gaussian mixture
problem I'll highlight some of these
results for hmms uh and in the next talk
Iran is gonna really give a you know
I'll highlight some very nice recent
work on learning this General gaussian
mixture problem because it's a sort of a
it's a very different sort of a tensor
it's a tensor made of PSD matrices so
this deck is really just gonna
go pretty slowly uh going through some
base cases of how we look at tensors how
these tensors arise in some basic models
in machine learning now suffice to say
there's really been a lot of work on the
cystics and computer science community
and these problems like the gaussian
mixture problem is a classic problem
dating back to Pearson
um
I would say this line of work for us
similar tensors have Arisen in different
areas for different reasons and this
line of work really
I think for me traces back to Joseph
Chang a statistician at Yale now where
he really understood some of these
identifiability issues for phylogeny
trees that sort of evolved into El
hanan's work and others but there's been
basically different lines of work
um that we can trace this back to
okay so so set up the problem for the
question of topic models and mixture of
gaussians definitely ask questions if
things aren't clear but we'll set up
these two cases I'll highlight what's
going on in these uh time series models
like hmms along the way and let's look
at the structure of this problem and see
how it's related to tensors and the
types of decompositions we understand
okay so let's take a simple version of
the gaussian mixture problem the
parameters are means which are developed
by mu random UK
let's generate our data okay so how we
can do it for each data point we're
going to sample a cluster I with
probability w i
and the point we observe is just going
to be this mean mu I
plus some noise we're adding to it and
let's say the noise is spherical for now
might have different uh variances so
long is going to look at the general
case later on
so so basically that picture I showed
you is we're just getting samples of
these means corrupted with noise
like here here's your data tell me the
parameters in the model
did you see a bunch of points and I'd
like you to tell me the Muse The W is
the signals and let me give you this
question for the topic model the topic
modeling problem
um which is you think of this as the
discrete analog of a mixture of
gaussian's problem but there's some
differences so the topic model problem
instead of means we have multivariate
distributions mu random u k Sorry
multinomial distributions immune name UK
and what we do now is first sample a
topic I would probably wi so a topic
might be Sports and the sports topic
just specifies a distribution over words
related to sports
where we generate our document now is
we're going to take M draws from this
particular multinomial distribution so
if we generate so if we choose a history
topic we're just going to generate
independently m words related to history
after this topic
and then
what you see are collections of
documents ignore the order in the words
and you'd like to group you'd like to
figure out what are sports topics and
history topics and so on where the
sports topic is the distribution of
words and in this hmm model
um you can think of this is just a
generalization of the topic model was
the topic model in a sense you can think
of this hidden State as being fixed
throughout the chain
it was an hmn you know the first word
could be generated according to one
hidden State then there's a transition
there's a different hidden state so so
in a sense these topic models are a
degenerate version of hmms where this
transition model is the identity
okay and again the hmm is you see these
sequences did you like to learn
hmm like models
uh sometimes uh
yeah so often uh they capture shorter
term time scales typically this is the
harder question is how do we do these
things hierarchically where H M's tend
to work better for like part of speech
structure because that's sort of faster
changing things and you run them in
practice the occasionally pick up topic
stuff but they're much better at picking
up
kind of the part of speech structure in
sentences
assuming okay for now the yes
I mean at some level you can search if
you have a polytime algorithm but uh
okay so what's the game we're gonna play
we're just going to look at instead of
Maximum likelihood let's just go back to
this old idea from Pearson which is the
method of moments and it's a simple idea
look at correlations in your data where
do the parameters consistent with the
correlations You observe right sometimes
referred to I mean this is the inverse
moments problem it's kind of studied a
lot in mathematics
and it's pretty intuitive so the mixture
of gaussian's problem is what are the
moments where the first moment is the
mean of your data the second moment is
the covariance Matrix the third moment
just specifies the three-way
correlations for the topic model these
moments are interesting because what is
the first moment of your data well you
can think of this as just specifying the
distribution of a single word
you're gonna get a second
moment as specifying The Joint
distribution of how often two particular
words occur in your document okay the
three word is how often do three words
co-occur in the document
and let's just forget about the
estimation of these movements like why
is the method in a moment it's nice from
Pearson because look it's easy to
estimate these moments in data the just
averages
right so
so let's just forget about
um the problem of estimation let's just
suppose we had exact moments ignore the
perturbation issue and see if we can
recover the model and now this is
interesting because we have an
identifiability problem because
suppose every document had one word in
it it's very clear things are not
identifiable this isn't even a
statistical question right this is an
identifiability question
and you know then the question is
suppose you had an infinite collection
of documents and they had two words in
them could you identify the model
what about three and and this is
interesting for hmms because uh
you know unlike this topic modeling
problem we only have a smaller number of
observations in the hmm right and and
this is sometimes referred to as the
minimal realization problem for hmms
which would be
you know kind of how long of Windows do
we need to look at before we can
identify the hmm there's an interesting
question here because
this we expect kind of more hidden
States than observations here
sure so it sort of seems unlikely that a
short window like you know how big a
window do we need to look at before we
can pin things down and in this parity
with noise example you know obviously
this is the worst case because there's
no finite window that'll ever work but
hopefully we're not in this bad case
okay so we're clear on the game the game
is now we're just going to look at the
structure that arises in these moments
and try to solve this inverse moment's
problem
and he's a simpler cases it'll be
relatively straightforward uh but we'll
start seeing some of the difficulties in
the wrong talk we'll see some of the the
very uh non-trivial difficulties
it's just for notation uh
we're gonna be in D Dimensions K is the
number of topics or clusters
so indeed dimensions and the topic model
problem think of d as the number of
words in our language
in this case D is four
uh the mixture of gaussian the one just
think of the expected value of x given
it some cluster I as mui this is just
conditional expectation uh with words
what's nice to use is what sometimes
call it a hot encoding which is uh
represent discrete words as binary
vectors where one entry is one which
corresponds to which word occurred
so so the reason for doing this is uh
it's sometimes nice to represent
multinomial distributions as vectors
right so the multinomial distribution
you could think of as atopic probability
vector
and and the reason this is nice is we
can say what's the probability
distribution over the first word given
word from topic I it's just this
conditional expectation which you can
write as the topic probability Vector
mui
all right so mui is a multinomial the
entry is seven to one and right is so
this sort of puts them on the same
footing
and this makes the linear algebra
notation a little clearer
okay so we go to this
and let's just look at these uh models
side by side what's the first moment in
our data it's just the average vector
it's the same thing in the topic
probability case the what's the
distribution over words in our language
it's just the average topic probability
vector
just to understand the sum of all me I
should be one uh this is say that the
sum of good say so let me just make this
clear
a mu I is in sort of a simple x which is
D minus one dimensional
so this is like the probability of say
0.7 0.2 as you can see history
uh
um
uh something this is basically each mu I
is the distribution we represent it as a
vector
it is it's convenient um
it's strange but it
oftentimes
uh with these discrete cases people
don't necessarily view them as vectors
but for these cases it's clearly the
right thing to do because we can write
these moments as vectors and then it's
clear why the joint distribution of
words is these topic probability vectors
this K of them
and uh for the Hmm this is
uh the distribute so now that we
actually will consider the order so the
distribution of X1 is actually the
distribution over the first outcome in
the sequence
these are the same it's clearly not
identifiable right I give you these
numbers exactly I tell you tell me the
Muse and the W's clearly it's not
identifiable
and things get interesting because now
we see differences in these two models
so let's look at the mixture of gaussian
model and let's just say our noise model
now is uh additive and spherical so all
gaussians have the same variance
pictures
what is the second moment it's just you
know the means plus noise but the noise
is Direction a specific so we have this
first component which is well first part
of the sum which is how the means relate
to each other so some of the meanwear
transpose and then we get this a
specific noise in all directions due to
Sigma squared so you ignore this first
order of perturbation but
it's a square you know the chi-square
distribution
this is the sigma squared identity yeah
because each uh I'm gonna assume for now
that but okay good so this is the
simplest case uh wrong is actually going
to look at a very general case uh but
let's look at this and what's
interesting about this is let's just
compare this to the topic model case
the distribution over two words in a
document
just because they're exchangeable and
independent is just the sum of mu wi mu
IMU I transpose because this is just as
if each as if both words were generated
according to the same topic and then we
just sum over those topics
this is really nice right because once
you condition on things they're
conditionally independent
and like what's the rank of this Matrix
1K
whereas what's the rank of this Matrix
D so
this is kind of nice right we it really
is a difference in these two and this is
we start really seeing the difficulties
of what goes on in these models is once
you start looking at you know higher
moments like each model for the most has
problems in its own way uh of how things
are getting jumbled together uh but
we'll try to deal with them
uh
so another question is suppose I give
you these exactly is it identifiable
I say here is the second woman exactly
can you tell me the Muse W's and sigmas
or can you tell me these distributions
probably not well it's clear for the
mixture of gaussian's case you can
because you said Sigma code is zero I'm
just saying here's a matrix tell me this
decomposition you can there's no
structure in it right it turns out even
for this uh topic model in case the
probability constraint really just
doesn't buy you much right you know it
comes from distributions you could
constrain them to line the simplex and
it's and it's not kind of a worst case
Theory thing like basically every uh
distribution of a pair of two words is
degenerate in like an uncountably
infinite way I think this was even in
maybe Joseph Chang's original paper he
gives me
one example but we generalized it and
it's really just degenerate but no
parameter cutting things are starting to
look good
because how many numbers do we get in
this second moment it's uh decrease D
Squared because it's a d by D Matrix
specifying The Joint distribution of two
okay
so you see where this is going right
like in
the taco end but that's given uh this
gaussian mixture problem model problem
it's a little annoying because we have
this extra stuff here and if we're gonna
look at the third moment and now you
have to remember how to you know
you had our class terms and deal with
gaussian moments so let's just ignore
this thing because it's it's immediately
clear what the topic model the third
moment it looks like
does that look like it just looks like a
3A it's like a very nice tensor
so sometimes just do some definitions
a second moment let's just divide it to
be M2 which looks like this
the third moment because
all the words are generated
independently
it again just looks like the average as
if the three words were generated
according to the same topic since the
sum of w i and your mui
okay
so right we can just forget about is
this clear
so now let's just forget about the
particular statistical model and just
think about this as a math problem right
this is a problem I give you a matrix I
guarantee you it has this structure I
give you a tensor
which is d by D by D I guarantee you it
has the structure and I ask you can you
tell me the Muse is it identifiable if
you can show me it's identifiable then
we at least answer the question that
documents need to be of length 3 for us
to identify the topics under this very
simple model
this is the simplest case but it's nice
like we can pin it down and of course
this is the stuff
um you know people in the room hear
experts on which is
tensor decompositions right and uh and
now we're considering this case where
the number of topics is less than the
number of words in the language
okay so sometimes in statistics we refer
to this and computer science we refer to
this as the under complete case but this
is pretty reasonable here uh what this
allows you to do is it allows you to
make these topics orthogonal so anytime
you have Matrix that's low rank it's
nice to whiten The Matrix so do a linear
transformation of the data that make it
look like the identity
okay so we're just changing the
coordinate system and this effectively
changes
kind of projects everything to a k
dimensional space
because basically we know the range of
the topics and so we make this look like
the identity this transformation allows
us to work in a k dimensional space it's
also nice in that it makes these topics
orthogonal to each other
okay so basically just do this
transformation it's linear and now we
have an even nicer reduction which is I
say here's a tensor it's a size K cubed
I guarantee you this decomposition
exists and these meters are orthogonal
if you can find it you can just you know
under your linear transformation this is
in orthogonal density composition so
you're saying you use the the M2 and
diagonalize it and use that
transformation on M3 exactly
yeah
right this is like this is sort of the
right way you know the earlier results
so hmms were confusing because it was an
asymmetric cancer and somehow the
community that understand them didn't
quite understand the connection and they
were doing simultaneous diagonalization
tricks and we kind of
it took us it took people a while to
realize this really was a tensor
decomposition because you had this
mysterious simultaneous diagonalization
problem because simony Hmm this really
is asymmetric because your tensors are
rising from the joint distribution over
three outcomes in a row
it's less than here so uh
so you just throw away the the smaller
numbers so so so so you're just
projecting the topics down to a d
dimensional to a k dimensional space so
you're going to cause the damage yeah
and this is actually good in practice
because in practice you know you never
want to write explicitly write down a
dense distribution over three words in
the language I mean technically this is
sparse but it's a horribly large tensor
saturation yeah that's right that's
right so this is actually practically a
pretty nice uh in the you know in the
empirical setting where you don't ever
want to explicitly
work you have to be careful about
working with a d Cube size object in
certain problems because D is very big
it's sparse but it's still big so this
is cuts down the dimension you know and
basically this is just the the sort of
the nicest generalization of the SVD
because you know if I didn't have this
this is an SVD all right and if I do
have this then we just inherit the nice
properties of uh orthogonal tensor
decompositions and you know the way we
Define
eigenvectors we can Define that for
tensor 2 which is an eigenvector of
Matrix is you hit the matrix by a vector
you get a vector I'm just defining kind
of notation here that this multi-linear
Edition is the tensor it has a few
indices if you hit it with vectors you
just kind of sum out uh the tensor with
each Vector so I'm gonna go over the
indices just like we do for matrices the
temperature eigenvector you can Define
it the same way and you know the
numerous people who have done work on
orthogonal and tensor decompositions
like tanjang and different communities
so we basically know that these things
exist
uh we know they exist
the basically what do we need for this
thing to work out we just need these
Muse to be linearly independent
and that's sort of what makes breaks
these hard cases
it's sort of a non-degenerate property
so this is really uh the proof in the
exact case we just
you know find the eigenvectors of this
tensor because it's orthogonal they
satisfy this property
right and uh what are the solutions of
the equation the v's have to line up
with the mirrors right this is the thing
we know and these are exactly the topics
this is classic you know estimation
problem sadistics well you have this
exactly that the tensor eigenvectors are
the topics in the language you just have
to unwind them
kind of name and it also hits the
identifiability question because no
at least for the single topic model we
need to know the documents of line three
and that suffices
basically going to break in this hmm
case because you know we needed this uh
K to be less than d
there's no way you can make get you know
K linearly independent vectors if K is
bigger than D so something's going to
break there
that this is the right intuition and you
know the theorem is pretty clear as long
as these mu as a linear independent the
uh eigenvectors of this tensor are in
fact the topics I call it robust just
because of the saddle point issue
and then
you know and why is this okay well you
know in general tensors are horrible
right for arbitrary tensors there's not
much
we know about existence of
decompositions any estimation in them
typically is just hardness results why
are things okay here well
you know I've I've posited the structure
of the tensor is coming from a cystical
model
that's why this is okay
so we mean that we know that in
journalism be hard but this one you
claim you have to give to convince miss
that this is easy yeah a little bit you
can solve this with uh so different way
to solve this is you can actually solve
this with two svds uh you yeah basically
you can actually one if it's exact one
way to solve this is actually doing two
single value decompositions we can do it
with a eigen
on one and then you claim that yeah
to be you already identified yeah that's
right an exact case there are many ways
to to prove this and
generically
yeah but what I'm saying the interesting
case now is the now we can go to Moses
question if we actually want to do this
in a reasonable way with finite sample
like the first time we tried this like
in practice this is when it became clear
you know from our community like look
this is clearly more structure in it
because the simultaneous diagonalization
methods they're kind of a bit of a
disaster in practice because you're
taking random slices and this power
method is much more stable but to really
address the cystical complexity question
and this part was interesting because we
have to understand what happens with a
perturbed tensor
we know who roughly where the algorithm
is going to be if we try this
eigenvector thing but we have to go
through the details to see how much
error we can tolerate and this is like
the analogs of these Matrix but
additional results like diviscohan
weeden's theorem but those are very nice
from matrices because what do you do in
The Matrix then you just take your
perturbed Matrix do an SVD on that it
exists and then talk about how close the
SVD on your perturb Matrix is to the
original you can't do this in the tensor
case because once you have perturbed
tensor you can't just say do the tensor
decomposition on this tensor because it
might not like the many different
methods is not guaranteed to exist so we
need an algorithm and now this comes the
kind of hair analysis part which is what
is the way we can not in the limit with
a finite with a quantifiable prohibition
and a quantifiable algorithm what can we
say about a Prohibition result in this
under complete setting so
this is there's that we have is
basically the sharpest you could hope
for
um because I don't have the details here
but but basically the do I have that
okay so basically the idea is you're
going to run
a power method on this
okay and use the results of a power
method and we're gonna do a pretty base
analysis but this is tricky because
because of the prohibition you aren't
guaranteed the power method will
converge
because you can actually because
basically if you start near a saddle
point the air ball around it we don't
know how to guarantee that you'll leave
so there's got to be some condition as
to how small the initial era is so you
can escape and then once you escape that
there's a question of do these things
really compound and and basically we
show here uh in some extent you know we
needed this just to do the sample
complexity result but it's really an
analog of whedon's theorem but what's
interesting in the tensor case in
whedon's theorem what really matters are
eigen gaps uh and Davis Gohan between
subspaces because that's when
degeneracies occur we know in the tensor
case
there's no degeneracies right you can
have
like in this theorem you can have wi's
that are repeated but it doesn't cause
you any problems because each one is
stable because this power of two so
somehow what's going to characterize the
stability of this problem can't be an
eigen Gap so the analog of kind of Davis
Kahan for tensors is actually how large
the eigenvalue is not the gap
okay so then basically formally uh the
way we prove this for a generic
perturbed orthogonal tensor is the
analog of Davis Gahan but we quantify
with high probability how many restarts
one needs uh how big the error region
needs to be because we really want a
polytime result here and there's
definitely a slop here in that
um the the initial error we need we
think could be smaller but the problem
is you have to sort of with enough
with high probability you want to say
you're going to start in a reasonable
place where the tensor power iteration
works
but at any rate the short answer is we
can do analogs of Davis Kahan for the
tensor case it's algorithmic dependent
that's important to really doing the
statistical analysis because that's I
mean that's in the paper but now it's
just how accurate do we estimate these
moments with data
what does that translate into parameter
estimate uh estimation and as far as we
can tell I think the best generic way to
do this is through this orthogonal
tensor decomposition and this
prohibition result as far as I know we
haven't seen it and it takes a lot of
work with the randomization to get it
right
in this method what you do essentially
you're trying to find the maximum
eigenbard or singular value right your
real tensor is symmetric I think
we want to find all of them not the
maximum
the maximum one is the one but here but
what so I mean because it's a big
argument of Maximum that you're trying
to find the marks right but but the
point is uh the thing about these
tensors is every
in The Matrix problem only the maximum
you'll find so generically in the tensor
one everyone is stable so what's
interesting about these tensors is we
actually want to find all local Maxima
so there's no guarantee we'll actually
find the max
imum
yeah
that's exactly the point the critical
points are unstable and this is exactly
the restarts we need because if you
start too close to a critical point you
could bounce around and we don't know
how to prove things so the actual proof
explicitly shows that with high
probability you are not get to a
critical point and basically what
happens in the the prohibition analog of
a critical point is if you're at a
saddle point we just don't know if
you'll converge so we explicitly uh and
sort of what governs the difficulty of
this problem is the smallest eigenvalue
of some topic so so we do actually
explicitly characterize this
so the first one you do it is maximum
then what's next oh no right so that's
the point we do the first one we might
not even find the maximum but we are
with high probability guarantine to find
one of them then you deflate you take
that out it turns out you don't even
need to deflate you just keep
randomizing you'll find them all
and this is like we this is exactly the
the difficulty the proof is actually
showing this for the orthogonal
intensity composition like in a sense
this theorem we did was just an abstract
one that had nothing to do with the
cystico problem it was just a tool we
needed to do this statistical efficiency
analysis and the finite computational
analysis uh but it's clear
it's in some settings we might have
structure for improvements but I think
in the genetic case
if we wanted to have a polytime
algorithm I think this is the sharpest
thing we could call it
yep
the August the independent analysis Yeah
so basically these these decompositions
arose in many different areas of
computer science statistics and so on
and some of the ICA Community they knew
their model really had the same
algebraic structure when you did
different manipulations but somehow this
connection wasn't made to
all the other latent variable models
which was very strange and it was like
20 years later but this is sort of
rediscovered in computer science and
these crypto results that uh
yeah this is again he rediscovered this
uh as well because he broke that crypto
Escape showing that you could solve this
problem and uh so definitely these this
community has studied these algorithms a
lot uh you know they're
kind of questions of Interest were a
little difference they didn't really
study the sound of complexity issues
directly uh but
not surprising this is a good idea it's
kind of been discovered in many
communities
yep
okay the speed of convergence all right
so yeah basically if you get close these
things are quadratic because you've got
this uh
uh this power too sorry
it's super fast yeah it's much faster
than the Matrix power method in this
case because uh because you have this
power too you got you get quadratic
convergence
yeah so this is yeah this is in the
paper but this is very clear that in
exact case it's crazy fast but it did I
mean the Gap depends on where you start
it's sort of which thing do you overlap
the most but you know it kills it
it's always quadratic based on the
overlap between whichever eigenvector
and sort of your starting point x like
that's sort of what the the
yeah it's always quadratic uh and but
but the sort of rate of like getting an
eigenvector method it depends on some
coefficient here it depends on the
starting point because I am confused
because the eigenvectors can be more
than a k you know because this is a
three-dimensional tense here I'm
assuming that there's only K in there
that's the the key of this
is
for me yeah that's right plus Alpha and
accent to the D these are very
non-general things yeah and that's
exactly why this we can solve this
because these statistical models give
rise to various specific tensors and in
a sense you're right for the hmm case
K is bigger than D so you can you can't
orthogonalize Okay so
yep
so do you get similar kinds of bombs
even if you consider the I mean take
into account the whitening still yeah
basically this just uh in in a sense
whatever whitening you do like this
doesn't say it statistically this is
just saying you have a t plus an error
tensor and you make some Spectra neuron
Bond on the error tensor so it's easy to
just say look up have whitening air I
just push that into the air tensor
and it was interesting sort of which
problems where the era dominates is it
the whitening step or the like in sort
of community detection this is uh yeah
this is a lot of delicate issues because
and if you have tricks to start closer
to some answer you can push this
original error ball down so I haven't
played this game for Community detection
so this
is
I just wanted to make sure I understood
what you're saying is that so you can
actually put down a grade of start
points run them all in parallel
different processors and find all the
eigenvectors you don't have to deflate
you don't have to yeah but that's
exponential time
the problem is that's exponential in the
dimension you can find them all
separately you don't have to um yeah
that's right that's right that's right
that's right so you don't want to do a
grid because that's exponential time uh
and it is exactly the sample complexity
issue for resampling a different way you
can do the proof is actually just keep
randomly restarting and and do it but
this is the key that in these high
dimensional things the grid is the
devastating like if you do that like we
didn't need the tensor to begin with I
could just sort of switch the switch the
space for the mirrors do you activate in
it
so let me they definitely take some more
questions but if we're good with this
one I would like to back up to this
mixture of gaussian's problem I kind of
swept that under the rug because this is
a super nice case but
this is clearly a
chicken problem
hey this bricks it's because you see if
you're if you are to mention the Smalls
and easily identify the lower end which
is closer yes but but that's right so if
the prohibition is small sure we can
throw this away uh but that's not the
case we want to solve we would like to
solve the general case because think of
this problem this is degenerate but
sometimes we're actually interested in
cases where a cluster is overlap and
statistically like if we didn't have to
worry about computation statistically
there's no problem identifying this
problem
so we do want to solve this problem and
there are definitely interesting cases
where we don't have these massively
separated uh calcium so certainly yeah
we could ignore the sigma by just
appealing to Prohibition but we want to
solve the problem the statistics problem
okay so how do we do that so I give you
this
what are you going to tell me
so can you tell me Sigma
foreign
and that's the point because you know
somehow in high Dimensions you're always
going to have Sigma uh Direction in in a
Direction with orthogonal to the means
right because because you basically in
all the directions you have at least
Sigma variance so you know the means of
in some Subspace so you can just rip
Sigma out and subtract it out and now if
you just look at the third moment what
happens well the third moment in this
problem basically just mixes up some
sigmas in there like what is the the
third moment of a scalar gaussian it's
like the mean plus three mu Sigma
squared
and that's the point here we can
estimate Sigma this third order moment
is just jumbling up some lower order
moments so you just subtract it and uh
they basically can play the same game so
take the second moment take the minimal
eigenvalue you subtract it out that
makes a piece that we want and think of
this mess as just three times the
variance times the mean and I'm just
kind of uh swapping things around to
make it work out in the tensor way but
by doing this I create moments that look
exactly like the the problem we can
solve
because I'm kind of uh yes this model
screws up the higher moments but we can
look at the structure in these moments
and take it out and I know this is a
heavily relying on the spherical noise
property
um
this particular Technique we can do the
different Sigma eye case but the most
General case of these are PSD matrices
and this is like a you know now your
tensors are made up of PST matrices and
that's so what I'm going to talk about
later
but the simplest case is giving us the
idea of what the game here is if we
really wanted to play this inverse
moments game sometimes there's tricks we
can play that can relate it to a tense
that we care about
uh and and that's all there is to this
this is basically the proof
then it's you know the sample size
issues are again just prohibition
arguments and respect to your point when
sigma's small yes you're going to need
more samples to estimate it but you can
still do it and you would expect that
because as Sigma starts becoming say as
signal sets becoming large you expect
the problem to become more difficult so
the sample size is going to grow but one
can quantify that and it behaves like
nicely it's not like exponential in
Sigma and somehow these bad cases are
basically degenerate ones
but there's an interesting bad cases
like hmm like
they get your mems like we do care about
this case because sometimes we do want
to model processes that are low
dimensional and have many hidden States
and just to end on on this
um you know what's the thing one would
try if if you had uh this process so if
it's a topic model is it degenerate what
you would what you'd like to do is sort
of group
words together and call them a word
they would like to look at a six tensor
and say well it's really uh attention
made out of the first two words I call
them a word and the second two and uh
and the third something like this so I
want to make tensors off of groups of
things together
okay so certainly this gives me more
parameters
and
and definitely things are becoming
exponential here so that's bad but the
point is
we have a lot of parameters to estimate
because suppose if we've got k-states
here
there's a k by K transition Matrix here
that we need to estimate so some amount
is reasonable
and this window size for hmm instead of
how big do we need to make these windows
for this to work out
so the topic model case it's sort of
easy to see that something like this
will work the problem here is once you
start blowing up these window sizes
is that
you're also blowing up the kind of
number of hidden States here
so this is interplay like if it was the
identity Matrix
then this is an easy problem because I
could tack these together and the hidden
State here is just the same it's only
one of K things
but in this hmm problem once you start
looking at larger windows this kind of
nice structure goes away once you look
at the it's still some structure but
it's a bit different because
somehow what you want to call the hidden
state is growing like also exponential
in your in your window size so you have
to be a little careful about this it
turns out you know this one we posted a
recent paper uh
basically arguing you know the parameter
accounting is about right so if your
window is bigger than uh sort of a log D
of K that's the the size of the windows
you need to consider uh so that's sort
of uh the moment the length of the
moments you need to
to use to estimate the model now the
subtlety is because you know there's
this classic problem in double e called
the Quasi realization problem where you
know you can represent hmms as automata
in different ways uh and that's how we
do it here and this game is to actually
learn it sort of in the model but but
the basic point is once Things become
overcomplete what K is less than D
sometimes the games the game actually
changes in subtle ways and and that's
what happens with this hmm problem
because
um yeah you have to play a few games but
but the high level point I'm trying to
emphasize is just that uh you know
what's the game try to look at the
structure in these models sometimes they
are related to things we can solve and
the related and things we can solve in
ways that we can both make computation
computational and statistical efficiency
statements both kind of quantify the
sample size we need the runtime of our
algorithm and understand what
properties of the problem govern the
difficulty things like minimal
eigenvalues and so on so
are you releasing genetically or do you
mean if you have some distance
so you're right so it's all right so
this is good so it's not a so this one
is not technically a smooth analysis
model so it's just if you with exact
moments
uh if you just perturb it and had exact
movements then you could solve the
problem
with with this but do you have mountains
you don't have strong bonds on the
prohibition and you know wrong and
changing thought about it and it's
delicate now the the gaussian mixture
one we do uh but somehow
it's subtle getting that I mean this is
the right question but it's subtle
getting that here because somehow
yeah like even the proof that it's
genetic like basically the proof that
it's generic was is difficult let alone
so it is compared to the results
so they give identifiability creams but
they don't have generic claims on
Windows
so
this is like in some sense uh this is
right because it says parameter
accounting is okay but it clearly breaks
for the periodic noise problem it also
is not smooth analysis which is what you
would really like
um and I think it uses some delicate I
don't know you probably like some
there's some uh delicate way of buying
eigenvalues away from zero for this for
this problem
Okay so
uh yeah and if you heard of LDA there's
like this topic model where you could
have many different things the same idea
kind of goes through so
um the short summary is the these ideas
are coming up in machine learning and
statistics because we have structure in
our models sometimes it's reasonable to
deposit the structure is reasonable uh
and if as opposed to worst case like if
we believe the model we should look at
the structure and the the problem and
these inverse movement methods do seem
to allow us some reasonable way to get
at parameter estimation these problems
or we can think about computational
difficulties cystical difficulty uh and
they seem to give be giving back to some
reasonable algorithms because basically
you know they're just trying to find
directions which your data is very
skewed and that's nice like it just even
has a heuristic this seems like a
reasonable thing to do in terms of
collaborators uh you know Daniel and
Emma I've been working on this for quite
some time all the tensor stuff are wrong
and I have been working on and uh the
ching ching was an intern this summer
and she did some really nice work with
us on this hmm problem and the gaussian
mixture problem that I'm just going to
talk about later thanks
are there any questions Michelle
um in the case when you have a dimension
B and the rank K in the practice what
could be the value of K and B for the
documents topic is for example you know
look at some of the problem is these
models are always wrong in practice so
the question is uh are these
abstractions a reasonable way to
estimate the problems I would say for
topics
like hundreds to thousands are
reasonable like looking at like hundreds
to thousands hundreds of thousands
topics no topics so what words you have
like so that's right so d uh I mean do
you know it's the number of words in the
language so typically if you use
Wikipedia you're looking at 10 to the
four to ten of the five uh you know 10
000 or 100 000 words uh and and uh okay
you know you would like your algorithm
to at least get 100 reasonable topics
but you should be able to get you know
you'd hope to get more there's a
question of interpretability of these
things which is an interesting question
but you know so from my perspective I'm
interested in using these methods it's
not so adamant that I really care about
topics but as like features to to
interesting problems and then like give
me as many as I can yeah like the more
features I get the better
do you know you're collaborous at any
question that an algebra is the
algebraic genre that might be able to
advance
how can we contribute
uh
well robustness is a big question uh
here so and this is sort of hitting the
limits where
we don't know what's happening because
uh you know this sort of in terms of my
very crude summary of the problems we
can we solve in this area we either
assume very strong modeling properties
which gives rise to the structure or we
assume like incoherence where these
tensors are very orthogonal and then you
can pull out like many many more out of
there so somehow
is there a way to think about what's I
mean it's a wide open area but it sort
of is a reasonable way to think about
something in between because
um
so I think robustness is one of the
biggest ones uh you know there's the
question on our side is are these
reasonable abstractions to the world
which I don't know like maybe these
things don't work on a lot of problems
but if that's the case why are we using
these statistical models anyway it is
kind of a refresh in my mind so right
because they these aren't anything's
fancy right they're saying look these
are the correlations we we expect to
arise in practice under the model if we
can't capture them in this model well
then what are we doing in the first
place
uh like maybe we should be thinking
about the problem very differently but I
would say robustness is
uh it is one of them finding some good
starting point I guess I would phrase it
as quantifying genetic genetics in some
ways so this is a yeah so it's all right
so quantifying generic-ness is a yes
yeah this is a nice way to put it and I
think a lot of the talks today are going
to be discussing that because yeah these
are all the easy cases I've we've looked
at and the hmm is a bit harder because
like any time when the overcomplete case
It's Tricky and you guys probably know
about this like Furby result by the de
la Tower there's this result when K is
like d choose two in generic you can
decompose one of these tensors exactly
this is really beautiful apply to do
that Tower and others and yeah
they're computational
yeah
um you mentioned this example with words
and topics
you have like 10 to 12 four words yeah
but then if you take a triple tons of
that wouldn't be the size is the size to
manifold or yes so the point is uh the
the number it sparse so uh the number of
things you're gonna have the number one
entry is going to be no more than the
length of Wikipedia because right okay
if you do exchangeable then it's a bit
more but it's still a super sparse like
if you just did in the hmm case it's
never going to grow past uh that that
size so you can definitely manipulate
these things as sparse objects but this
is why the white like in practice the
whitening step seems to be better
because you can actually take the tensor
make it a k-cube size object a thousand
cubed is fine and at that point what
seems to be actually better in practice
is to actually use like alternating
least squares like start reasonably and
that really works works well it's fast
uh but yeah so managing you know spice
is like
nothing particularly deep there the
answer but it's interesting that the
time it takes to manipulate these these
things typically is just the
construction of the tensor and the
projection the actual power method or
whatever you're doing or the alternating
these squares like it it's super fast
it's literally just reading your data
constructing this object whitening and
that's it
okay the normal question this time song
again
and we come back at 10 points yes